so one audience member in attendance at
last night's nbc
town hall with president trump went
viral on social media her name
myra jolie seated right behind the
president seen
for big part of the night nodding along
to many of the president's comments
given a thumbs up at one point
are here to react to the viral trump
supporter from last night's town hall
myra joe lee and civil rights attorney
our friend leo terrell
myra thank you for joining us okay did
you expect
you become a viral sensation by the way
it's sort of like leo leo's a viral
sensation
i certainly didn't expect that because i
thought that
sensation was the president himself but
i'm glad i could help
why you were nodding i'm assuming
in agreement it seemed like it was an
agreement um
i mean i picked it up on my own then all
you know people started tweeting look
look over the president she
there's a supporter in an nbc town hall
of the president
um was it nodding in agreement
absolutely not not in an agreement
because i was following exactly what he
was saying
and that's my sentiment as well not
emotionally
but from the logical point of view so
it's just
just natural to follow the conversation
and then
when you feel like what the person is
saying is correct
i noted in approval how did you feel
about the treatment of the president by
savannah guthrie
it's like like like every other
presentation that the president has had
it's all it's time it's
it's like the president is fighting with
one hand tied
behind his back in which the judge
and the prosecutor are both against the
attorney practically
so there is no way that anybody can have
a decent conversation when from the
get-go
is just attacked and it's not only a
town hall
it's been it's been it's been the norm
throughout the whole candidacy and
president of the
of the president trump and
their supporters aka myself
i am not being a victim of attacks just
because
i just was sitting behind the president
happened to be sitting behind the
president
i've been the victim of attacks just
because
i expressed my views and i'm a person
who
think on her own and i'm a grown woman a
businesswoman
and i believe that that's the right
that's the right that i do
have to come to this country and think
for myself